I think it cannot be territorial but it
takes a long time yeah that's an
interest that's a really interesting
question because I think you know it's
something like a marriage can't start
out as a very situation which two people
hardly know each other and they are
naturally going to be a bit territorial
I have a young woman friend who has
difficulty in relationships because she
really cannot stand to have anybody put
anything in her refrigerator just or
move anything is not refrigerated so
that's has a kind of a really open /
territoriality but I think most people
have these little limits around them and
that when you fall in love you willing
to break those down a bit it depends on
how far you willing to go bad things can
happen when one side of the of the
relationship is more territorial than
the other and the other is very willing
to give everything up and the other is
very willing to take everything when you
can wind up with some quite onion and
unhappy situations but I do think it is
possible for people to become so
committed to one another's prospering
and to one another's flowering that they
can't get past this you know the Italian
Way of saying I love you is not I need
you or I want you it is I wish you will
it's such a it's such a surprising thing
to say if you say it to somebody who
it's a very intimate thing to say you
would not say it to a relative would
always say it to a lover I wish you well
I really like that notion that that's
what love is
you know I don't think it doesn't happen
as often as we might think mean I think
long-standing relationships can can have
this element but sometimes the
relationships can have really bad
periods you know I mean let's think
about the Clintons have they arrived
there yet yeah they have certainly been
through the back and forth of it I don't
want to judge that relationship wouldn't
want to be in it but but a relationship
with long-standing that's been tested
and tested and yet indoors has got
something in it I think it may be
pathology but but it could be it could
be something worth having
hmm